[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM MURRAY: My
name is Tim Murray,
and I work on the
Android performance team.
And we're going to talk
today about improving
your application's
performance on Android.
Now one of the big things that
the Android performance has
done in the past year was
to optimize the performance
of the Google Pixel.
We looked at everything on the
Pixel, from application code
all the way down to the
kernel, everything in between.
We tweaked things.
We experimented with things.
We replaced other
components entirely.
What did we try to do here?
What did we do to--
what was our focus
for performance?
Number one, we wanted to hit 60
frames per second all the time.
This means that you have
to render a frame in 16.7
milliseconds all the time.
If you run at 60 frames per
second, your app looks fluid.
Your app looks smooth
and responsive.
If you don't run at 60 frames
per second, people notice.
The phone doesn't feel fast.
The phone feels like
it's struggling.
So that kind of
consistency is paramount.
You really want to hit 60
frames per second all the time.
The second thing
we focused on was
to make applications
start quickly.
A user will switch
between applications a lot
in the course of normal usage.
You know, if I'm in
Gmail and I click
a link that opens in Chrome,
I want that to go quickly.
If I click a link
in, you know, Chrome
that takes me to Twitter, I
want that to go quickly, too.
Any time that I'm sitting
there waiting for the system
to switch applications
feels like dead time.
It's time when I
remember that I'm
using a computer as
opposed to just interacting
with that stuff I
want to get done.
So reducing the amount of
time you spend switching apps
makes the system
feel effortless.
It's really important.
That's it.
That's what we focused
on system-wide for Pixel.
We just wanted to hit those
two things consistently.
If you do these two
things, when your device is
switching between
applications very quickly
and running at 60 frames
per second, it'll feel fast.
But more importantly,
if your device
runs at 60 frames per second
and switches between apps
quickly consistently,
it does it all the time,
the device stops
feeling like anything.
It stops feeling like a device.
Instead, it feels like
you're interacting directly
with the application.
And that's magical for a user.
That's really important.
But there's a problem
with this scenario.
We run apps, and
apps can be slow.
And of course, on the
system side of things,
we're constantly trying
to make it easier
to write fast applications
and make it harder
to write slow applications.
But fundamentally, as an
application developer,
there's always going
to be something
you can do to make the system
not run at 60 frames per second
or make your app start
up really slowly.
The issue is that from the
point of view of the user,
they don't care that it's one
app that happens to run slowly.
One app that doesn't run at 60
fps or doesn't start up quickly
ruins that whole magical
feeling of a device.
And it reminds them that they're
not interacting with an app.
They're touching their
phone, and then they
want to throw their
phone against the wall.
So today we're going
to talk about two tools
that we used during
Pixel really extensively
to analyze performance
and help you
as app developers figure out
what you can do to improve
your application's performance.
The first tool we're going to
talk about is called gfx info.
So gfx info is a shell
command that you can
use on the device via dumpsys.
And all it does is it tell
you about the rendering
time for your application.
So here we can see that
we rendered 223 frames.
We get the average frame time,
the 90th, 95th, 99th percentile
frame time.
And then it gives us some idea
of why things were actually
slow.
We use this a lot
internally, and we really
just look at average
frame time, 90th, 95th,
and 99th percentile frame time.
And that's it.
That's all this tool does.
It doesn't tell you
why your app ran slow.
It doesn't tell you anything
that you should do to fix it.
So why am I up here
talking about it?
Because you can automate it.
If you take one thing
away from this talk,
if you decide to take a
nap for the next half hour,
just run gfx info at the very
end of whatever automated task
you're running.
And congratulations, now
you have a performance test.
Now you have a thing you
can run regressions on.
You can spot regressions
in your application.
The first time you have
a performance regression
in your application that
you want to track down,
this will save you so
much time and effort,
it will pay for
itself instantly.
This is how most of the internal
Android jank tests work.
This is how we track all
jank across the system.
It's incredibly useful.
Please just do it.
You'll save yourself
so much time.
But OK, that's gfx info.
That only tells you where
your performance is today.
It doesn't tell you why
your performance is that way
or what you should do about it.
For that we have to turn
to a different tool,
my favorite tool, really,
the only tool I ever use--
Systrace.
So a lot of developers
have tried Systrace,
and they've told me they
have no idea what's going
on when they look at Systrace.
And that's fair.
I can stand up here and tell
you that Systrace is easy.
It's not really easy.
Systrace is not a CPU profiler.
Systrace is instead a
system wide tracing tool.
The first thing that
means is, Systrace
doesn't care about your app.
It doesn't do anything
special to your application.
It's not going to go
peek at your applications
call stacks and say, hey,
you spent a really long time
in this function.
It doesn't do that.
It just tells you
when your application
was running and
certain events that
occur within your application.
It also tells you everything
about the rest of the system.
It will tell you things
about the kernel.
It'll tell you things about
the graphics pipeline.
It will tell you things about
the framework and activity
manager and things like that.
Really, if there's
any information
you want about an
Android device,
we have probably
surfaced it via Systrace.
We use it for everything.
Just to be-- just to reinforce
how important Systrace is,
in the past year, I've looked
at somewhere over 2,000 traces.
We use Systrace a whole lot.
Now Systrace is not
in Android Studio.
If you want to get Systrace,
there are two ways to get it.
First of all, it's in platform
tools in the Android SDK.
You can get a version
of Systrace from there.
What I like to do,
though, is I get
Systrace from the repository
where it's developed.
It's part of a project called
Catapult, which is on GitHub.
Cantabile?
Catapult is owned by members of
the Google Chrome and Android
teams.
So upstream Catapult
is always improving.
There are always new features.
I usually get top
of tree Catapult.
Once you get that, you'll have
this Python executable that you
can run, and you
can get a trace.
Now how does Systrace
actually work?
What does it actually tell you?
Systrace is three components.
At the bottom is this
thing called ftrace.
Ftrace is a Linux kernel feature
that allows the kernel and user
space to write event information
into a central buffer.
What this means,
basically, is that you
can get a journal of any event
that happened on the system.
So the kernel will tell
us things like, hey,
this process started
running on this CPU,
or, hey, the clocks
changed on this CPU.
That's great.
It's really low level,
but we can use it.
The next thing above ftrace
is a program called atrace.
Atrace is a Android
program on the device that
is installed automatically
and the Android image,
it's on every device.
All it really does is it
configures the ftrace.
But it also configures
user space tracing.
So atrace will go
and turn on all
of these different trace points
inside of the Android user
space.
So here we can get
things like, you
want to find out what
Window Manager thought
about your application.
Atrace will turn that on.
Or Activity Manager,
or any other part
of the Android framework, all
of that is controlled by atrace.
The top most layer
is Systrace itself.
Systrace then lives on your
host development machine,
and it gets the
results from atrace
and it wraps those results
in a nice HTML file.
You get this giant,
potentially tens of megs
or even hundreds of megs, HTML
file that contains a trace.
So all you have to do to look at
the trace is you open the HTML
file.
It's pretty convenient,
and it actually
makes sharing traces
incredibly easy.
Now the first
thing you should do
when you decide to
start tracing a device
is you should look
at the categories
available on that device.
Systrace events are
separated into categories.
And those categories
will vary from OS version
the OS version, and
potentially device to device.
In general, the important
stuff will always be there.
The core stuff that you
want as an app developer,
we have tests for that, so
they'll be on every device.
Now let's actually
run a trace and see
what that would look like.
So this is the command
I used for the trace
you'll see for the
rest of this talk.
And the way Systrace
works is you
provide the list of event tags
that you want in your trace.
And here we have sched, which
is the kernel scheduler,
we have freq for CPU
frequency information,
idle will tell us about
when the CPU goes idle, am
and wm tell us about the Android
Activity Manager and Window
Manager, gfx will tell
us everything you ever
wanted to know about the
Android graphics pipeline,
view will tell you
about the view hierarchy
inside applications, which
can be really useful,
dalvik enables the trace
point for the Arc VM,
input will tell you when you're
actually touching the screen,
and binder driver will
tell you exactly when
a process is making an IPC call
over binder to another process.
The last three
arguments are special.
Dash t just says we're going
to run the trace for 5 seconds.
If you omit the dash
t, Systrace will just
prompt you to press Enter
when you want to stop tracing.
Dash o just controls
where you write the file.
So you can write the I/O dot
HTML instead of trace dot HTML.
Dash b is a little odd.
So I mentioned ftrace
and the f buffer.
The ftrace buffer
is a fixed size.
By default, it's, I
think, 1.4 megabytes.
And what happens if you fill
this buffer, if you have
too many events for the buffer,
is you'll get a trace, and then
at the end, things will
just kind of stop happening.
You think you ran the
trace for 5 seconds,
but maybe you only actually
have 3 and 1/2 seconds
worth of events in there.
When I take a trace, I always
increase the buffer size.
So here I've increased
it to 16 megabytes.
And for this kind
of trace we probably
don't have to increase
the buffer size,
but it's always better to
increase the buffer size
and not have to take a
trace a second time then
be overly conservative
with the buffer size.
All right, we run this,
we now get a trace.
What does a trace
actually look like?
There is a lot going
on in this trace.
And if you're in
the back, I'm sorry.
It's probably
really hard to see.
The first thing to
know about the trace
is that it is a timeline view.
It moves left to
right, and you can
scroll it left to right, and
time moves from left to right.
So the left side here is
the beginning of the trace.
That's zero seconds when
we kicked off the trace.
And five seconds is
when the trace ends.
You can move around the trace.
You can pan in time
with a and d keys,
and you can zoom in and out on
whatever section of the trace
you're looking at with w s.
So it's just wasd, like
a first person shooter.
The trace also
scrolls up and down.
So here you see there are
a bunch of rows up here.
There's this kernel section,
and then a calculator section.
There are way more rows
than fit on the screen
because there is one row
generally for every thread that
is run during the trace.
So you may have
hundreds or thousands
of rows in your trace.
The next thing to look at
when you start using Systrace
is there is this
palette of tools
that I have over here in
the upper right hand corner.
You can click on these tools.
You can also access them with
numbers one through four.
Number one is the pointer.
That's the main tool we
use when we use Systrace.
That lets us click
the individual events
that we see in the trace and
get some information about them.
And when you click an
event, it will show up
in the bottom half of
the screen like that.
So here we can see
calculator was running,
we see the process ID, we see
the thread ID, the priority,
we can see when exactly
it started in the trace,
we see how long it ran for.
You get a bunch of
useful statistics.
You can also use the
pointer to select
a lot of different things
in the trace, which
gives you a aggregate
view that looks like that.
And so this will
basically add up
all of the threads, like if I
select the region in the kernel
section here, this will add
up all of the threads that
occurred and tell
us how much time
did we spend in each thread.
Well, what was the average
time that each thread ran?
Things like that.
That's really useful.
We'll come back to that later.
Number two and
three on the palette
are for panning and zooming.
So they're equivalent to wasd.
You don't need to use them.
You can use them if you want.
I generally just use wasd.
The fourth tool though
is incredibly useful.
It is the highlighter tool.
So you can select a region
of time in the trace.
And that region will
have a white background,
and everything you
haven't selected
will then have a
gray background.
You can use this to keep track
of the area you care about
as you scroll vertically
through a trace.
So if you find
something in one process
and you think, something
went wrong here,
what else was the
system doing, you
can scroll up and down
the trace and know exactly
what part of the trace
you should be looking at.
I use the highlighter
constantly.
If you start using Systrace,
you probably will as well.
Now let's scroll down and see
what else is in the trace.
More stuff.
So every row in a trace is
either a counter or a thread.
And down here at the
bottom is a thread.
These blocks right
here are the core thing
that you will look
at in Systrace.
These are events.
So every Systrace event
has a beginning and an end.
Systrace events
can then be nested.
So this is a stack
that grows down.
You can see that here a
choreographer event happened,
and a traversal event
was contained entirely
within that event, and more
things happened beneath.
This is some stuff that's part
of a calculator app startup.
And you will see a lot of these
as you look through a trace.
Each event it corresponds to
explicit place in the Android
code base that somebody
thought, hey, maybe somebody
will need to figure out that
this is happening sometime.
It's good to pay
attention to these.
Now let's zoom in on
the beginning of--
or at the end of Activity
Start for calculator.
So in this trace, we
launched calculator
and clicked a few buttons.
Here we are at the very
end of Activity Start.
And I zoomed in really closely,
and it's still probably
hard to see because Systrace
has a lot of very small UI
elements.
But there are these colored bars
on top of the UI thread here.
These colored bars
represent the state
of that thread at
any point in time.
There are five different
states that a thread can be in.
Now if we click the green
bar above the UI thread
in the middle, we see
that at this point
the thread was running.
So at this point, the thread
is actually running on a CPU.
It's running on CPU 1.
And if we were to scroll back
up to the kernel section,
we would see it's
scheduled on CPU 1.
This is how you can know that
your application is actually
running at particular
times on the CPU.
The next state that we
care about is runnable.
Runnable means that
your thread could start
running at some point in time.
Nothing is preventing
your thread from running.
It's just that the kernel
has not scheduled it yet.
There are any number of
reasons why this could happen.
Maybe there's more
higher priority work.
Maybe your thread has just
run for a really long time,
and a scheduler is trying to
be fair and give other threads
an opportunity to run.
There are lots of
reasons for this.
But if you're seeing a lot
of this in your application,
it's probably due
to thread priority.
The third thing that you
can see on the right hand
side of the trace here
is there's a red bar.
And the red bar is
uninterruptible sleep,
which sounds a little
scarier than it is.
Uninterruptible
sleep is your thread
is blocked on some lock
inside of the kernel.
As an application
developer, there's
generally not much
you can do with this.
Sometimes it's hardware related.
Sometimes it has
to do with memory.
Usually, if you see a lot
of uninterruptible sleep,
it's my fault. It's
a system problem.
So we're probably aware
and trying to fix it.
But sometimes you can see
it's related to memory.
You can get some more
information about it.
The fourth type of
state is a special kind
of uninterruptible sleep that
as an application developer
you can actually
do something about.
The orange state here
is your sleeping--
your thread is sleeping
on block I/O. This means
that your thread is
reading from disk,
and the disk hasn't gotten the
results back to your thread,
so your thread
can't make progress.
If you see a lot of
this in your trace,
you're just reading
too much data.
Try not to read so much data.
The fifth state,
the last state, is
the state you'll see most often,
and it's usually white or gray,
depending on the back
end of the trace.
It just means the
thread is sleeping.
The thread has no work
to do, so it is asleep.
It's not running.
The scheduler isn't
trying to run it.
Nothing is working on
behalf of that thread
directly in the kernel
or anything like that.
If you see this a lot and
you think that's weird,
it's probably due to some
user space lock interaction
because user space locks
will show up as sleeping.
The last thing you can do
with these colored bars that
is really great is you can
select all of them in a region
that you care about to
get aggregate information.
So here we can see
we spent so much time
sleeping versus
runnable versus running.
I do this constantly.
This gives me a
really coarse idea
of what the bottleneck is for
a particular piece of code.
I can take a trace and see,
hey, this thread is running.
It's on the CPU.
It should be making progress,
but it's just taking too long.
What's going on?
It means that it just has
too much CPU work to do.
If it's getting CPU time
and not running fast enough,
all you can really do is
reduce the amount of CPU
work it has to do.
Now if I take a trace and I
see that a thread is always
in block I/O, then
I know it's reading
too much data from disk.
So don't read so
much data from disk.
If you're sleeping
where you don't expect,
it probably means that
your application logic
is a little weird somewhere.
You probably have some
weird priority inversion
to something, or lock contention
that you didn't expect,
something like that.
Another useful tool on a trace
is I mentioned the input tag
earlier.
And up here at the
very top, there
is this tiny little
box for input response.
And this shows where
I actually touched
the screen and the trace.
So here I touched the screen,
and I guess my finger was down
for 28.8 milliseconds.
You can use that in a trace
similar to the highlighter.
You could use that to orient
yourself in the trace.
You know what's going on.
If you remember what you were
doing while creating the trace,
you can figure out where
exactly you are logically inside
that trace.
But what if you need more
information than this?
What if you have a
lot of information
about what your app is
doing logically that you
want to get in a trace?
Good news.
That's pretty easy.
So there is a class,
Android dot os got
trace, that has two methods--
begin section and end section.
If you put-- you can put
a string in begin section,
and that will just show up
as an event in the trace.
It shows up the same
as anything else.
The only special thing
you need to keep in mind
here is you need to
call trace dot end
section from the same
thread every time you
have a begin section.
If you don't have a
one-to-one mapping
between begin section
and end section,
your trace will look weird.
You will get very weird
rendering in your trace.
And it's just because
you forgot a end section
or you had too
many end sections.
If we take a trace, and we
want to see the app events,
we have to do a little bit
more than we did initially.
First, we specify
this app tag as part
of the arguments to
the trace, and then we
have to pass dash a
and the package name
that you care about.
Then you just take a
normal trace like that
and you open it up, and
you see this trace event,
which is just whatever
you put in your string.
If you have logical groupings
of work or a logical task
that the user is doing,
adding a trace event for that
is really useful.
When I look at large, complex
applications within Google,
I find that the applications I
can debug easily and understand
performance of easily
are the ones that
implement their own
application trace events.
I definitely recommend doing it.
It's not that difficult, and
it will be worth it as you
start looking at Systrace.
It will make Systrace a
lot more comprehensible.
And for reading a
trace, that's about it.
There's not really that
much going on in a trace.
It's just sort of
what the system is
doing at any point in time.
And everything that the system
is doing at any point in time
ends up looking like this.
So now what?
I don't think most of you
probably feel that comfortable
using Systrace yet.
So why would we want
to use Systrace?
What is Systrace going to tell
us that makes it so useful?
Let's go back to the two
goals that we had for Pixel.
Number one, 60
frames per second.
Number two, it makes
appa start quickly.
OK, yes, Systrace could
tell us some things
about this directly.
But there is an
underlying principle here
that we should call out.
Don't look slow.
That's it.
That's really the only
performance rule there is.
The reason why we
use Systrace is it
can tell us where we look slow.
And note that I said,
don't look slow.
I didn't say, don't be slow.
This may sound weird
coming from a person who
works on performance, but
for any moderately complex
application, at
some point in time,
you're going to have to
do something that is slow.
Maybe you're going to do
some giant matrix multiply
for some reason.
Maybe you're going
to read from disk.
You have to read a large image.
Maybe you have to talk
to the network, which
could take who knows how long.
At that point, you
want to understand
why did the system
end up looking slow
when I was doing this,
and then what can I
do to work around this.
You know you have to
do this slow thing.
What can you do in
your application
to identify where exactly that
slow point happened, and then
work around it to make the
system still look fast?
Because that's all
the user care about.
They don't care if the
system is slow or is fast.
They just want the
system to feel fast.
If you do that, it'll be great.
Now let's apply that to
the two goals that we had.
App startup.
The basic thing with
Systrace and app startup
is you can use
Systrace to figure out
exactly where your time is
going during app startup.
Then you can decide
what to do about it.
And there's no one size
fits all advice here.
Really you have
to understand what
your particular
application is doing,
what the needs of
your application are,
and then you can come
up with a solution.
The first thing that
we use Systrace for
to analyze app startup
is view inflation.
Here we have this inflate
section in a trace.
This is from the very
beginning of calculator,
from Activity Start
in calculator.
And we have this really
long inflate section.
But more importantly, we can
see the exact cost of inflating
every view for calculator.
This is really useful
to help you figure out
the cost of a view hierarchy
or changing of view hierarchy.
You can say, is it
actually worth 50
milliseconds to inflate
all these ways right now?
Could I do this later?
Could I do something
else instead?
You have to come up
with whatever solution
is right for your application.
But Systrace can
help you figure out
what is actually happening
today in your application.
So you can come up with those
improvements and those ideas
for future changes to your app.
Another thing that
Systrace tells you is you
can tell exactly when
application startup ended
from the user's point of view.
There's more than just bind
application and Activity
Start in application startup.
Here you can actually see
the UI thread and render
thread of your
application, which
are the two most important
threads in making
your application run at
60 frames per second.
And we know that once
those threads have
finished for the first time--
here you could see the UI
thread running and finishing
this choreographer doFrame
along with the render thread
running at the same time--
once that's done, the
app is actually loaded
and ready for user input.
At that point from the
user's point of view,
app startup is done.
Another useful thing in Systrace
is the resource tag, res.
So you can look at
exactly what resources
you're loading in
your application
at any point in time.
Usually, loading resources
is not a huge deal.
Occasionally, we've seen
areas where resource loading
can be expensive.
It's worth checking
in your application.
It will tell you, just
as the name of an event,
exactly what resource you're
loading and how long it takes.
And again, you can
figure out, is it worth
letting this resource right now?
All right, let's move to jank,
because that's the more fun
one.
Fixing jank with Systrace
is a two-step process.
Number one, you need to figure
out where the jank actually
happened because
maybe you can spot
every time the system doesn't
run at 60 frames per second.
But I've been doing this
full-time for a while now,
I can't even do that.
So Systrace can help make it
really obvious where exactly
you dropped a frame.
The second step that
you use Systrace
for is working your
way backwards from the
dropped frame to what
actually went wrong.
And then you can figure
out what to do about it.
So here we have a UI thread
and render thread, again,
in an application.
And we're running the thread,
or the application, normally.
It's not a janky frame.
It's just normal 60 frame
per second rendering.
The UI thread is the
main application thread.
That's what actually gets input
events from system server.
Render thread actually gets
information from the UI thread
and sends that to the GPU.
This means that in order
to display a frame on time,
the UI thread and
the render thread
have to complete within 16.7
milliseconds every time.
This gives Systrace a
nice kind of rhythm.
You can get used to this
rhythm when you open a Systrace
and say, oh yeah, I
dropped a frame there,
because you can tell it
didn't quite line up.
It makes it easy to spot
where the UI pipeline didn't
run at a full 60
frames per second
once you get used to this.
Now if that's not enough, you
can look at SurfaceFlinger.
So we're not going--
we don't have time
to go through the
full Android pipeline.
But the high level overview is,
your app will render a frame,
and it will send that frame
over to SurfaceFlinger.
SurfaceFlinger is
a system service
that will take whatever app
is rendering on the screen,
and it will combine that with
a navigation bar and the status
bar, and actually send the
resulting full, completed
composite frame to the display
to show up on the screen.
What this means is
that SurfaceFlinger
is the central source of truth.
If ServiceFlinger thinks
you hit your frame deadline,
you're running at 60
frames per second.
If SurfaceFlinger says you
didn't deliver a frame,
you know you didn't actually
hit 60 frames per second.
And here the way we can do
that is we have a counter here.
There is one counter per
application in a trace.
This counter here is
alternating between zero and one
for how many frames
the SurfaceFlinger have
from this application that
are ready to be displayed.
So you know that
if the counter goes
to zero for more
than 16 milliseconds,
you have definitely
missed a frame.
This is the ultimate way to
know whether you had jank
in your application or not.
This gets us-- this helps us
spot where the problem is.
It helps us know where you
actually dropped the frame.
So what do you do when you
know where the problem is?
You're going to work
your way backwards.
So we're going to
look at SurfaceFlinger
to work our way backwards.
We're looking at
SurfaceFlinger just
as an example of a
relatively simple chain here
because application chains
can be more complicated.
We don't quite have time.
But usually, you want to
know why something woke up.
So we have a running
state in the application,
and we want to know
what made it runnable
because that will tell
us why the thread woke up
in the first place.
So here I clicked the running
state on top of SurfaceFlinger,
and I can hit the
left arrow, and I
can see the runnable state.
Now I have the runnable
state selected,
and I want to go ahead
and highlight that.
You can highlight
anything you currently
have selected with the m key.
Now we have a nice
little bar showing what
we're looking at in the trace.
In this runnable section, we
have an additional argument
at the bottom here.
And it says, wake
up from tid 529.
This means that the
SurfaceFlinger thread
was triggered by thread 529.
Now I don't know
what thread 529 is,
but I do know that thread 529
must be running at this point
because if thread
529 wasn't running,
it couldn't have woken
up SurfaceFlinger.
So I can scroll back up
to the top of the trace
to see what is actually
running on the CPU,
and I see this
thing, event thread.
So I'll click event thread.
And event thread is
part of SurfaceFlinger.
It's another thread inside of
the SurfaceFlinger process.
And now I want to know
what woke up that event
thread because
I'm working my way
backwards to figure out
why SurfaceFlinger woke up
at all here.
So I'll scroll back down
and find event thread inside
of SurfaceFlinger, and
there is the actual thread
state for the event thread.
We just have that
little colored bar
to show that it's running
because it doesn't have
any events during that time.
We can click the runnable
section of the event thread
and see that it woke
up from thread 4568.
Now I cheated.
I know what thread 4568 is.
It is the display sync thread
that is also in SurfaceFlinger.
So let's go to that one and see
what woke up the display sync
thread.
That's right down
there, we click it,
we see wake up from tid 0.
Tid 0 is a special
thing in a trace.
And all it means is
that whatever thread
you were looking at was woken
up by an interrupt or some sort.
It was woken up by
an interrupt handler.
Usually this means
a timer expired.
This makes sense
for SurfaceFlinger.
SurfaceFlinger will run
every 16 milliseconds.
So a timer expired,
woke up this display
syncronization thread,
which in turn woke up
the event thread, which
then woke up SurfaceFlinger.
If you see this in
your trace, it usually
means that some timer expired
and woke up your thread,
and that's why you're running.
And that's it.
That's the basics of what you
need to know to actually get
somewhere with Systrace.
Take some traces
of your application
and just try to see
what's going on.
Look at the system.
Look at how frames are being
drawn and sent to the display,
and how you're getting
touch input from the server.
This kind of tracing backwards
via the runnable state
is most of what we
do to understand
how the system fits together.
And you can use it to improve
your applications as well.
Now if you want a lot more
advice on what you should do,
as opposed to how to understand
what's going on today,
I recommend you go to the--
there's an additional
performance
talk specifically
on the UI pipeline
that Chet Haas and
Chris Crake are giving.
It's at Friday at 1:30 PM.
So definitely go to that.
I know they're going to talk
a bunch about recycler view
and optimizations there, which
is always a popular topic.
So that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]